vestida de luto y aún recuperándose de
sus heridas así aterrizó de regreso en
haití martí moix la viuda del presidente
haitiano jouvenel moix tras recuperarse
en un hospital de miami su arribo se
produce días antes del funeral de su
esposo pautado para el 23 de julio en la
ciudad de cap-haitien la primera dama
martín moix acaba de llegar a haití en
el marco de los preparativos de las
honras fúnebres nacionales del
presidente job en el mois fue recibida
en el aeropuerto internacional por el
primer ministro cloud joseph joven el
mois aún no está en la tumba pero su
ausencia repentina ha desatado una lucha
por llenar un vacío de poder sumiendo al
país en una inestabilidad política aún
mayor
claude joseph ha liderado haití con el
respaldo de la policía y el ejército a
pesar de que maurice lo había
reemplazado por ariel henry por decreto
dos días antes de su muerte el
presidente del senador joseph lambert se
encuentra entre los que se disputan el
poder del actual premier interino
insiste que él debe gobernar sin embargo
ha pedido apoyo para resolver la crisis
del país
factum
ariel si soy el primer ministro de facto
ariel enrique es el primer ministro
designado pero nunca fue nombrado joseph
lambert es senador es presidente del
senado pero no es presidente de la
asamblea nacional porque la cámara de
diputados no existe así que nosotros
tres y los otros sectores tenemos que
unirnos para encontrar una solución
en un servicio no obstante en un revés
para claude joseph el llamado core grupo
integrado por embajadores y
representantes de la oea y naciones
unidas dio un espaldarazo a ariel henry
para la tarea de formar gobierno el
grupo hizo un llamado a que se realicen
elecciones legislativas y presidenciales
justas y libres cuanto antes la
oposición haitiana duda que pueda
llevarse a cabo en menos de un año dada
la crisis que atraviesa el país